okay both of your children got married
this year yes summer
i love it 2020 the year of so many plans
put on hold
but both of your kids went ahead and did
it
you know it was really extraordinary i
mean everybody has
has had loss through this whole season
of covid many people have missed out on
things they were really really looking
forward to both of my children were
planning big weddings
and um cassie's was first and uh in her
her fiance's
childhood home 150 acre farm in michigan
it ended up there were 18 people and
then cody was married in our backyard
over
labor day weekend and that was the we
got bigger we were 19 people at that one
he married his longtime love erica and
it was you know what it turned out to be
such a blessing drew because it got down
to
exactly what a wedding should be about
it's not about how many people you have
how much it costs how much your dress
was i mean
literally it's one day in your life but
cass said and ben said to me mom
we want to be married we want to be
married
so can we can we just and i said yes it
makes me so happy
especially since i'm the mother of the
bride and i was going to have to pay for
it
now we actually have um a guest in the
wall who wanted to ask you a question in
our
vffs i believe you have a question
um what advice would you give your 27
year old self
do everything your mother tells you to
do and you'll live a fabulous
life and you'll marry the language and
become an oscar-winning actress do what
i did
ladies and gentlemen this is cassidy
kathie lee's real life daughter
oh you little peanut cass how are you
i love you how are you guys hi drew
hi cassidy i'm so glad you came on
mothers and daughters
is kind of my everything it's uh it's
you know i'm a mom of two girls and i'm
so happy for you that you had this
beautiful perfectly toned intimate
gorgeous wedding
this year and that you guys have so much
hope and joy to bring about in this year
that has been so difficult for so many
people and i know everybody's going
through it but i just feel like your
story
uh really resonates with people thank
you so much drew for saying that truly
it probably sounds like i'm full of it
but i would not
trade a single thing it was about what
it was supposed to be about
and we're just kind of in bliss about it
all
so and it's been wonderful and thank you
so much for both of you being here
mothers and daughters it's my favorite
thing
and thank you so much love to you both
nice to meet you so thank you too drew
yeah you're a naturalist you are so
lovable that's
honestly congratulations you were uh
just i didn't know i love you as an
actress love you
when you come on our show in the past
but i didn't know
what you would be like wearing this
other hat and it fits you beautifully
your chapeau mademoiselle
you have made me very emotional today
for many reasons
i have a deep amount of respect for you
i always have
i always will and to get your seal of
approval is a very big deal for me
so i thank you as a woman and a mom and
someone who i have loved as we all have
watching you on television for so long
and we're just celebrating your film
available on demand i think it's going
to be a smash hit
you